Strom immer da bei Tag und Nacht der
Preis zieht bei uns und in vielen
anderen EU-Ländern mächtig an deshalb
klären wir welche Rolle spielt Gas in
unserem Energiemix
wie kommt der Strompreis zustande und
welche Möglichkeiten gibt es den
Strompreis zu steuern
unser Strom wurde 2021 in diesen Mengen
aus den unterschiedlichen Energieträgern
erzeugt die erneuerbaren Energien
lieferten insgesamt etwa 46%. den
größten Anteil durch Windkraft bei den
konventionellen Energien lieferten die
fossilen Brennstoffe Kohle und Gas den
größten Anteil da wir bei den
erneuerbaren Energien auch vom
wetterabhängig sind schwankt derenanteil
im Strommix und damit schwankt natürlich
auch der Anteil der anderen
Energieträger Gas spielt in diesem
Zusammenhang eine wichtige Rolle es ist
bei der Energiegewinnung
umweltfreundlicher als Kohle war ähnlich
günstig und ist vor allem ein sehr
flexibler Stromlieferant wenn es an
Strom durch erneuerbarer Energien fehlt
kann mit Gas sehr genau und schnell
reagiert werden und der Bedarf gedeckt
werden das können Kohlekraftwerke so
nicht leisten jetzt allerdings bekommen
wir die Quittung für unseren Hang zum
ehemals günstigen Gas
teure Gas bestimmt unseren Strompreis
[Musik]
um die Preisentwicklung grundsätzlich
nachvollziehen zu können ist es wichtig
zu wissen dass Strom zu sehr
unterschiedlichen Preisen erzeugt wird
verschiedene Anlagen Kosten in
Herstellung und Betrieb unterschiedlich
viel dazu kommen bei den fossilen die
aktuellen Brennstoffpreise und die
co2-abgaben damit immer ausreichend
Strom da ist muss es eine optimale
Abstimmung zwischen Stromverbrauch und
Stromerzeugung geben denn Strom kann
kaum gespeichert werden diese genaue
Abstimmung passiert dann auf dem
Strommarkt der Strompreis verändert sich
dort nach dem marktwirtschaftlichen
nachfrageangebot Prinzip wird im
Verhältnis zur Nachfrage ausreichend
Strom produziert ist der Preis eher
niedrig gibt es eine hohe Nachfrage und
muss mehr produziert werden steigt der
Preis
der Handel mit Strom verläuft in
unterschiedlichen Zeitabschnitten er
wird einerseits langfristig geplant und
gehandelt mit Vorlauf über Monate und
Jahre für diese langfristigen Verträge
gibt es einen Preisaufschlag auch um
Preisveränderungen abzufedern sehr
zentral ist jedoch auch der kurzfristige
Stromhandel der Vorlauf liegt zwischen
einem Tag und dem Minutenbereich er
ergänzt die langfristige Planung denn
der Bedarf kann ja nie genau
vorhergesagt werden da er von vielen
Faktoren abhängt in der momentanen
Energiekrise sind uns vor allem zwei
Dinge zum Verhängnis geworden wir
produzieren zu wenig günstigen Strom aus
erneuerbaren Energien denn der Ausbau
ist ins Stocken geraten und der hohe
Gaspreis denn der teuerste Strom der zur
Bedarfsdeckung nötig ist bestimmt den
allgemeinen Preis schlecht für uns
Verbraucher gut für Energiekonzerne die
mit anderen Energieträgern günstigeren
Strom produzieren denn alle können nun
den Strom zum teuren Preis verkaufen
[Musik]
genau bei diesen unverhältnismäßigen
gewinnen wollen EU und die deutsche
Regierung nun ansetzen eine Gewinngrenze
könnte für die Energiekonzerne
eingeführt werden alles was darüber
hinausgeht könnte abgeschöpft und
umverteilt werden außerdem sollen Öl und
Gaskonzerne eine Solidaritätsabgabe
leisten auch die Entkoppelung vom Strom
und Gaspreis wird von der
Bundesregierung geprüft in Deutschland
wurde 2021 nur ein geringer Stromanteil
mit Gas produziert dass der nun beim
Preis so ins Gewicht fällt scheint
unverhältnismäßig
einige EU-Länder fordern daher auf
diesen Gasanteil zur Stromerzeugung
einen preisdeckel deutschland lehnt das
ab einig ist sich die EU das Konzerne
gemeinsam auf dem Markt gaseinkaufen
sollen so können Sie den Bedarf bündeln
und den Preis drücken
ganz wichtig bleibt aber wir müssen alle
mit Energie besser haushalten umstellen
auf LEDs Geräte ganz ausschalten
Standby auf energieeffiziente Geräte
achten und vielleicht auch mal auf das
eigene Dach schauen jede
Photovoltaikanlage hilft bei der
umweltfreundlichen Energiegewinnung
[Musik]